un gendarme ont intercepté un
automobiliste qui roulait 50 km au
dessus de la limite autorisée
et comme excuse il a invoqué souffrir
d'un trouble obsessionnel compulsif
c'est à dire d'un toc
voilà il n'y à toc voilà donc ils
précisent conduire toujours à 110 km
heure pour que l'aiguillé de son
compteur soit droite dans le sens de la
direction de marc 70 km avec des énormes
le gard les gendarmes lui ont retiré son
permis et il est également passible
d'une amende allant jusqu'à 1500 euros
est-ce que vous avez des petits tics des
petites toques des critiques toc
oui sur les pavés je marche droit
j'essaie de toujours suivre la ligne en
fait sur les pavés j'espère s'assoit sur
les pavés ont fait ça soit durable et
que je fais pression vous avez une vidéo
fera pas le wifi verdez moi j'en ai
beaucoup y en a bien un qui est un peu
compliqué à vivre c'est que je passe mon
temps sous le lit est en fait je vais
souvent des noms mais ça fait pas ça
c'est bon c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
tous vous dis coucouche panier
[Rires]
et vive voix lui dit robien allez
revient un vrai alors oui et donc parce
que je ne supporte plus le moindre grain
de poussière sous le lit non donc je
passe des vous devriez faire une chanson
avec ses lignes en dessous de grands
coups sûrs et j'adore oui et donc je
prends tout ce que je peux des
essuie-tout ladd et des lingettes je
gratte sous le lit sous le lit sous les
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient plus rien non
mais quand y'a plus rien on s'en va on
revient il y en a encore alors moi j'ai
une très bonne solution pour vous
l'hôpital psychiatrique très tranquille
souhaiterait donc et qui à l'époque
qu'élu
moi j'ai un gros problème avec mon chien
la nuit là eh ben je suis obligé de
mettre à rêver toutes les heures la nuit
pour regarder si elle respire encore non
genre si je me réveille et je mets ma
main comme ça et si ça soulève comme ça
je me dis ça va je peux me rendormir
tranquille ah oui qu'elle dort le long
de mon corps si tu es un mec pareil
moi je fais ça avec montréal est pareil
avec son mec elle voit tous si ça se
lève c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
face à l'aso mais qu'elle appelle le
cosy
c'est ça mais c'est parce que qu'elle a
l'instinct maternel elle veut protéger
comme un nouveau né est inversement
j'adore son à l'intello de la banque a
fait l'actualité
oui elle est en maternelle un jeu qu'on
en a tapé un voyagiste les bons côtés
contrairement à vos balais bouquet vous
allez les voir pour vous seul chez vous
l'année prochaine vous cette foule ni
enfin de faire la poussière n'existe
vraiment pas me faire chier aujourd'hui
oui bonsoir madame quel âge avez vous
sans blague et je fais ça avec mon mari
je me lève pour voir s'il est encore
vivant de temps en temps et vous fait
quoi
accessible tant à oui mais c'est pas ça
mon stock
moi j'ai un vrai vrai tank avec les
plaques minéralogiques vous avez un toc
c'est vous défendez m6 même quand les
éléphants
voilà ça c'est le premier tome il ya ils
peuvent faire de téléspectateurs mais
plus qu'un succès pendant alors oui j'ai
un vrai casier une des voitures devant
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de faire
l'addition des chiffres les plaques
minéralogiques awer exemple 3502 ps 38
je fais 3 + 5 + 0 + 2 way en 1502 ça
fait celui ci à bois tu vas pas faire
des choses et d'être nous faire chier
ces craintes étaient intacts a quoi
comme tout les éclaboussures les
éclaboussures vous savez des éviers
quand ça gicle
ouais mais dès qu'il ya des petits
dépôts comme ça autour d'olivier ça me
rend complètement dingue et donc je
passe l'épongé le torchon comme fait
paniquer vous faites c'est du propre
pression en fait la nouvelle émission la
verrine queen non non non non pas parce
que si les éviers dégueulasse avec
l'inox avec des traces comme ça de
calcaire et grâce c'est insupportable
ah ouais c'est donc tout reste toute la
journée hélas au lave-linge de leur bus
longtemps alors oui t'as quoi là bas va
essayer d'être bronzé tout le temps
parce que tu as tu le vois en fait et
blanc comme un cube non mais alors lui
monte c'est comme ça il a toujours bonne
mine
tu le vois vraiment en vrai tu le
laisses de semaine chez lui on voit la
honte explique en immersion qui
partenaires d'or et lui va être blanc
comme ça arrête je peux te dire c'est un
blanchiment des dents à matelas mien
c'est bruno guillon moi c'est la
poussière
c'est la première est la poussière
je passe ma vie avec l'aspirateur
j'adore ça des je vois des traces par
terre ou démis de pain vous savez après
un dîner tout ça je passe l'aspirateur
systématiquement oui c'est vraiment un
vrai top c'est la taille soit un bon
truc tu sais portatif à ça s'est bien
passé
on a un titre daytona mais si cette
norme avec joie d'énergie elle me dit
ginette dyson et donc je suis obligé de
l'enlever mais vraiment oui c'est vrai
c'est matin et soir
c'est fou ça c'est un vrai toc allez
donc là tu vas rentrer chez toi tu as
enlevé les miettes ouais mais répond que
tout ton slip c'est là je sens que mes
[Rires]
bébés mois avec les aspirateurs ce que
j'aime faire aimer quand vous enlevez le
truc et calories et unicom
[Rires]
mais là je mets sur les surf comme un
symbole de sol mais j'adore ces génomes
une vente ou un vrai comme une vente
umlauf et des marques après on se sent
pas mais qui est devenu un puissant
parce qu'il avait essayé le sens aix
dans la spirale je sais c'était mon ami
notamment elle est ensemble le sait bien
alors comment de la rue n'ont pas fait
attention de pas vous retrouver dans le
sac poussière
quelques éclairs abîme ci gît dans le
truc là c'est monsieur qui arrive oui
castaldi c'est quoi toi alors moi je
connais des gens qui restent c'est qu'on
fait à un dîner les gens et après ils
prennent un café après ils prennent un
verre il fait part jamais mais moi je
fais quoi je prends un aspirateur et je
passe l'aspirateur vous obtiendrez sympa
et c'est vrai que ça m'énerve et je fais
un pas joli mais le moment à temps quand
tu as fini qu'à ce toit de chez moi
mais les drire s il raisonne pas comme
ça me fait chier passe moi je vous dis
des gros rush et vous non parce qu'on
dit forcément on sait très bien vous
inviter des potes à vous bien loin et
fait donc fait pas de cause ils
forcément il va pas pouvoir dormir avec
toutes ces femmes dont ils vont rester
bas oui oui mais surtout de tuffé genre
mais quand on dîne chez toi tu fais 4
sieste pendant le repas donc été proche
des 7 il a juste je pouvais
[Rires]
edgar des conneries mais c'est bon alors
puis encore des tops c'est bon alors oui
oui je suis battu c'est un toc mais moi
toute la journée je vais voir les sites
d'infos si j'ai pas raté une info médias
un truc comme ça
c'est fou de ma gueule